Olá aqui o Dr Alan Machado Dutra médico
há mais de 25 anos e hoje eu vou
compartilhar com vocês seis suplementos
naturais para aliviar os sintomas
indesejados da menopausa muitas mulheres
sofrem com esse sintoma desagradáveis
quando chegam nessa fase da vida uma vez
atendi uma paciente que durante a
consulta me disse que chegou na
menopausa e estava com muitos sintomas
Ela me perguntou o que poderia ser feito
para melhor sintomas dessa doença
menopausa primeiro é importante lembrar
que menopausa não é uma doença a
menopausa é uma data a data da última
menstruação o que nós chamamos de
menopausa geralmente é o climatério que
é um processo natural pelo qual toda a
mulher passa mas isso não significa que
deve ser negligenciado ou tratado sem o
devido cuidado enquanto muitas mulheres
passam por essa fase sem ter sintomas
significativos outras enfrentam
desconfortos importantes que precisam de
atenção e tratamento os sintomas do
climatério
menopausa incluem ondas de calor suores
noturnos alterações no sono insônia
dificuldade para dormir oscilações de
humor secura vaginal e falta de libido
além desses sintomas é importante Estar
atento ou atenta a problemas mais
preocupantes que podem surgir nessa fase
como doenças cardiovasculares
osteoporose diabetes e demências outro
ponto importante é o ganho de peso já
que o climatério Barra menopausa pode
facilitar o acúmulo de gordura abdominal
que é mais perigosa pra saúde portanto
com todos esses sintomas e fatores de
risco o climatério pode ter um impacto
físico e emocional significativo por
isso é importante é fundamental tratar e
olhar para essa fase com cuidado e
atenção OK agora vamos falar sobre
remédios naturais para os sintomas do
climatério menopausa Não estou me
referindo a medicamentos ou reposição
hormonal mas sim plantas e ervas
naturais que são seguras na maioria das
vezes quando utilizado nas doses
corretas elas podem ser muito úteis
nessa fase de transição então vamos
conhecer essas ervas a primeira erva é o
vitex vitex Agnus castos também
conhecido como chased Berry o vitex é
super popular entre os remédios naturais
pro equilíbrio hormonal ele é ótimo para
aliviar aquelas ondas de calor que
tantas mulheres sentem durante o
climatério Barra menopausa Além disso se
você está tendo dificuldades para dormir
por causa das alterações hormonais o
vitex pode ser uma grande ajuda
Pesquisas mostram que ele ajuda a
equilibrar a proporção de progesterona
em relação ao estrogênio trazendo um
equilíbrio hormonal de forma suave e
natural a segunda erva que vamos
discutir aqui que eu quero apresentar é
o black coros também conhecido como
cimici funga racemosa essa erva é
fantástica para prevenir os sintomas da
menopausa especialmente aquelas temidas
ondas de calor e suores noturnos e
Estudos indicam que o black coros pode
melhorar a qualidade do sono e ajudar a
equilibrar os hormônios Além disso é
útil para condições comuns durante o
climatério Barra menopausa como diabetes
e ansiedade mas atenção em doses altas o
black coros pode afetar o fígado então é
importante usar com sabedoria e com
acompanhamento médico o terceiro
suplemento e um dos mais usados
recomendados paraa climatério Rem
menopausa é o famoso óleo de prímula tem
muitos estudos clínicos ensaios
randomizados que analisaram os seus
efeitos em mulheres na menopausa e
descobriram que o uso do Óleo de Prímula
pode diminuir a intensidade das ondas de
calor e reduzir a perturbação causada
por esses sintomas é uma ajuda em tanto
Ok Além disso Pesquisas mostram que
ingerir o óleo de prímula junto com
ômega-3 pode ajudar a prevenir a perda
óssea o que é super importante para
evitar a osteoporose uma condição que
pode afetar mulheres nessa fase
climatério barra menopausa o óleo de
prímula é rico em ácidos grassos
benéficos como o ácido Gama linolênico
que ajuda a equilibrar os hormônios ele
não é eficaz só para o sintomas da
menopausa mas também pode ajudar com a
atenção pré-menstrual tpm e até
contribuir para a fertilidade de
mulheres nessa fase
fértil o quarto suplemento também bem
famoso é a maca peruana a maca peruana é
uma raiz super nutritiva rica em
antioxidantes vitamina C cobre e ferro
ajuda a reduzir os efeitos do estresse e
também os efeitos do envelhecimento no
corpo além de diminuir os níveis de
cortisol isso é especialmente benéfico
para mulheres no climatério que estão
sentindo muito estresse a maca também é
ótima para reduzir as ondas de calor
aumentar a energia e combater a fadiga
então a maca contribui pra manutenção de
um peso saudável e pode até ajudar na
emagrecimento a maca também melhora
libido a energia da mulher tornando-se
um suplemento Super
Interessante pessoas com problemas de
tireoide devem ter cuidado ao consumir
maca e só deve utilizar com autorização
médica e mulheres que estão utilizando
medicamentos que alteram os hormônios
especialmente pro tratamento de doenças
como é o caso do câncer de mama câncer
de útero ou de ovário também deve evitar
a maca escutar as orientações de seus
médicos se você está entrando no
climatério a caminho da menopausa e
procura uma forma natural de aliviar os
sintomas a Angélica censes conhecida
como Dong qu uma erva chinesa é uma
ótima opção ela não só alivia os
sintomas da menopausa mas também pode
ajudar com depressão essa erva melhora a
saúde do coração reduz a inflamação e
pode até diminuir os níveis de açúcar no
sangue assim como óleo de prímula a
Angélica censes também ajuda na
prevenção da osteoporose fortalecendo os
ossos ela possui um leve efeito
estrogênico fraco o que ajuda a regular
os níveis hormonais e consequentemente
aliviar os sintomas do climatério Barra
menopausa Além disso Pesquisas mostram
que o uso combinado de Angélica censes
com camomila pode reduzir a frequência a
intensidade das ondas de calor em até
96% bem impressionante não é a sexta
erva é o hipericum perfur conhecido no
Brasil como Erva de São João você
provavelmente já ouviu falar da Erva de
São João certo ela pode ser utilizada
como chá extrato ou cápsulas e é
incrível para melhorar os sintomas de
depressão e ansiedade inclusive aqueles
relacionados à menopausa estudos mostram
que a erva de São João pode melhorar de
forma significativa os sintomas
psicossomáticos e psicológicos das
mulheres na fase climatério em caminho
para menopausa com até 76% das
participantes relatando que esses
sintomas desapareceram completamente
Além disso muitas mulheres relataram uma
melhora no bem-estar sexual após o
tratamento com a hera de São João o que
também contribui para a melhora geral
dos sintomas psicológicos agora é
importante lembrar que os efeitos
colaterais D suplementos que eu acabei
de falar são raros Mas eles acontecem
eles podem acontecer inclui dor de
estômago náusea erupção cutânea coceira
e dor de cabeça e atenção sempre
verifica o seu médico ou médica antes de
tomar qualquer um desses suplementos
especialmente se você esver grávida ou
amamentando ou ainda se esver histórico
de câncer sensível a hormônios ou
estiver tomando anticoagulantes
medicamentos para pressão arterial ou
antidepressivos mulheres é essencial
ouvir o seu próprio corpo e prestar
atenção às mudanças que está enfrentando
se você esver no climatério no caminho
para menopausa ou se você já está se
aproximando dessa fase saiba que é o
momento de cuidar de si mesma com muita
atenção muito carinho Procure um médico
ou médica que possa te ajudar e faça uma
prevenção adequada compartilhe os vídeos
faç bem a vida de alguém pode mudar
também
[Música]
can Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração e
você é o quê você é fera a